this episode of the live files is
brought to you by huel
on November 2nd 1966 Woody derenberger
was driving home from a business trip
when he encountered an extraterrestrial
being named Ingrid cold cold
communicated with Woody telepathically
and the two went on to be lifelong
friends other people close to Woody
including family friends and even his
therapist claimed that They too had
experiences with Ingrid cold Woody wrote
and published a detailed account of his
experiences and never went back on his
story and since the 1960s the legend of
Ingrid cold has become one of the most
famous in all of UFO lore and take it at
face value the story sounds strange but
the real story it's much stranger
[Music]
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
okay so uh not my best not your best you
should be embarrass
energy there'd be a tag on your toe I'm
tired okay I'm tired
I think it might be time to give up this
content creator thing don't you dare
talk like that I
Gibraltar and I am not
go coconut Diner in fresh now what Adam
and Eve on a raft with a mystery in the
alley a cowboy with Spurs 86 cow feed
and a shingle with a shimmy the shank
pick it up and give it shoes what you
need is training kid yeah I don't know
if that's really
[Music]
you're in worse shape than I thought are
you following a diet plan I gave you oh
I don't have time to hunt for
nightcrawlers okay okay I got just the
thing going to my secret compartment on
your desk
look behind my Starsky wig
you sure this isn't Hutch it's Dusky you
know the only thing back here is this
mini Arc of the Covenant don't know
don't open it what evil ghost will fly
out of it really and melt my skin well
there are many evil ghost so it's more
like ringworm eczema but it's still very
itchy no way this that's it heal Black
Edition is a nutritionally complete
convenient affordable food with minimal
impact on animals and the environment it
provides you with all the carbohydrates
protein fat fiber and 27 essential
micronutrients your body needs to thrive
they make a bunch of great flavors too
uh but there should be some chocolate in
there ready to go
how is this cold drink it
[Music]
let's get 40 grams of protein it's
naturally gluten free it's got zero
artificial sweetness and less than five
percent sugar it's got green tea extract
and there's a full plant-based meal it
tastes great plus it's easy on the
wallet
I am feeling better
what's that training montage
[Music]
down up down
into that comment another comment been
that user tweet insta tweet is the
Facebook
[Music]
that you did it kid
is fuel today sponsor sure is check out
heel black edition by go to my.hill.com
the y-files July we first order you
receive a heel t-shirt and a guide to
get you started well it sounds good but
what's this for oh the chicken we use
that in a sequel
Woodrow Wilson derenberger who went by
Woody was for Mineral Wells West
Virginia and he was an ordinary
Appalachian man in the 1960s he worked
as a Salesman for a sewing machine
company in early November 1966 Woody was
returning from a business trip when his
life changed forever around 7 30 pm on
Route 77 in Parkersburg West Virginia
Woody heard a crashing sound behind him
he looked in his mirror and saw a
brightly lit vehicle charging behind him
at great speed Woody thought it was a
car until the vehicle flew over his van
and stopped in the road in front of him
would he hit the brakes and the object
hovered in front of him a few feet off
the ground Woody was paralyzed terrified
he had never seen an object like this he
described it as looking like an
old-fashioned kerosene lamp sitting on
its side a tube with a bulge in the
middle it was dark gray like charcoal
and the craft made a deep humming sound
that reminded Woody of a helicopter then
Woody started to panic a door on the
side of the craft opened and out walked
a man just an ordinary looking man maybe
about 40 years old average tight average
build and dressed in dark colors as soon
as the man stepped out of the craft the
door closed and the object shot straight
up into the air the man walked directly
to Woody's van and came right up to the
passenger side window the man looked
completely average though he had a tan
and dark slick back hair he was smiling
amiably and then gestured to Woody to
roll down the window which he did the
man said why are you frightened we mean
you no harm Woody he heard the words and
understood them but the man's mouth
didn't move he just kept on smiling like
this the man asked Woody his name and
said he's called cold and he was a
Searcher from the planet lanulos then Mr
cold asked Woody some mundane questions
about the town they were in what kind of
work would he did in basic small talk
and after a few minutes of friendly
conversation Mr cold said telepathically
that he had to be going the craft then
came down nearby and the door opened as
Mr cold climbed back aboard the ship he
turned back and said telepathically it's
been nice talking to you Mr darenberger
we'll be seeing you soon the door closed
then the ship shot into the air and out
of sight Woody derenberger was in shock
for a few minutes but soon he was able
to compose himself he went home and told
his wife what happened he then went to
the police but Woody didn't have to wait
very long for Mr cold to keep his
promise because the very next day Mr
cold was back
foreign
[Music]
Woody darenberger didn't realize at the
time was he wasn't the first to see the
strange visitor he was seen a few weeks
earlier on October 11th in Elizabeth New
Jersey about an eight-hour drive from
that West Virginia Highway at about 10
pm a UFO had been reported in the area
the first eyewitnesses to this event
were a police officer and his wife they
described the object as a blazing white
light as big as a car it almost crashed
into a television Tower then slowly
disappeared behind some hills nearby the
UFO was then seen on the opposite side
of the Hills this time the Witnesses
were two police officers on patrol it
was so bright it almost blinded them the
light was brilliantly white it lit up
the whole area for about 300 yards in
fact it blinded me when I got out of the
patrol car to look at it and I couldn't
see for about 20 minutes afterwards that
same night a woman in the next town over
saw a flash in the sky then a
cylinder-shaped craft landed in the lot
where her car was parked the ship opened
and two ordinary looking men came out
they asked her strange questions in a
weird dialect then they got back in the
ship and flew away at about 10 30 again
on that same night two teenage boys were
on their way to play Pinball they were
crossing underneath the New Jersey
Turnpike when they saw the strangest man
they'd ever seen he was standing
directly across the street behind a
fence they thought maybe his car had
broken down but he was in a place no one
could get to accessing the spot would
have required crossing a very busy
highway and then climbing a steep
30-foot embankment it would be crazy to
try the boys said this was the biggest
man they'd ever seen almost seven feet
tall and Broad he was wearing green
coveralls that glittered he was
originally facing away from them but
then he slowly turned around he had
Beady wide set eyes and a giant
unnatural grin The Boy is bolted at
first they didn't tell anyone about this
experience but then they heard about the
encounter in the parking lot that same
night and figured they'd better report
it a week later the boys were
interviewed by John Keel a writer from
New York City John had been drawn to the
area by this rash of UFO sightings all
happening around the same time after
interviewing the teenagers separately as
well as together John Keel believed they
were telling the truth Keel would name
this entity the grinning man and write
about him in his book strange creatures
from time and space a few weeks later
John read about Woody derenberger's
encounter in the newspapers and saw he
had given an interview on television
Woody seemed to be describing the same
entity scene in this area of New Jersey
and now the entity had a name he's
called cold
[Music]
to viewers of the y-files John Keel is a
familiar name Keel was an investigator
and author most well known for his
theories about ultra-terrestrials
specifically the Mothman if you didn't
see that episode it's linked below but
here's a quick recap the Mothman is a
large winged creature with red eyes
that's been spotted all over the world
but the first sightings were in Point
Pleasant West Virginia beginning on
November 15 1966 that's three days after
Woody's first encounter with Mr cold and
just an hour's Drive Away Keel was in
town investigating Mothman sightings as
well as all kinds of other paranormal
events happening in the area one of
those events happened at the home of
James Lilly and his family the lilies
had been reporting strange noises and
Poltergeist activity they thought maybe
their house had become haunted doors and
cabinets would Slam in the middle of the
night it was the sound of a distant baby
crying and every night about 5 PM the
phone would ring and when they answered
they would hear what they described as a
bizarre metallic voice speaking in an
incomprehensible language they reported
the calls to the phone company but there
was no explanation they'd also been
seeing unusual lights above their house
almost every single night we've seen all
kinds of strange things blue lights
scream ones red ones things that change
color some have been so low that we
thought we could see diamond-shaped
windows in them and none of them make
any noise at all
but the most terrifying incident
happened to the Lily's daughter Linda
who is 16 years old one night Linda
heard a noise in her room that woke her
up she opened her eyes and there was a
man leering down at her it was a man a
big man very broad I couldn't see his
face very well but I could see that he
was grinning at me he walked around the
bed and stood right over me I screamed
again and hid under the covers what it
looked again it was gone
whether the grinning man was injured
cold is hard to say but the events all
happened during the same week the night
of Woody's first encounter two
construction workers were driving south
from Marietta Ohio heading to their
homes near Point Pleasant West Virginia
then a strange flying object appeared
over the highway and settled in front of
their car a man in shiny coverall
stepped from the object walked over and
engaged the men in a seemingly pointless
conversation he wanted to know where
they were from what they did for work
and where they were going he didn't
offer any information about himself and
the men were too frightened to ask
questions after a few minutes The
Stranger returned to the object and it
floated quietly into the night sky the
two men decided to keep their mouths
shut because they didn't think anyone
would believe the story they only came
forward after Woody went public with his
story one family saw the ship right
after it stopped Woody derenberger they
watched the object for about five
minutes until flew out of sight and
later a young man driving on the same
stretch of road reported the object
hovering over his car and Blasting him
with extremely bright light he reported
this to the police the day after Woody's
and these other encounters with cold a
TV producer came to the store when Woody
worked and asked him to go on television
that afternoon which he did
[Music]
whether or not you believe in
unidentified flying objects or not is
not the point
what do you believe in what you hear or
see on this program is not the point
we are here to talk to a man that
allegedly
did make contact
with such an object
within the Parkersburg area last evening
Mr danberger
[Music]
in your own words would you please
relate what happened last night
[Music]
and this man stood there and he he first
asked me what I was called and I'm
eating it my name and I told him my name
and he asked me he said why are you
frightened he said don't be frightened
we wish you no harm he said we mean you
no harm we wish you only happiness
I told him my name and when I told him
the name he said he was called cold
Woody was peppered with questions for
half an hour but he remained calm
consistent and believable
did he ask you what you did for a living
where you were he asked me he he asked
me if I if I worked for a living
and I told him and I was a Salesman and
he told me that he was a searcher
a Searcher a Searcher but he didn't tell
you what he was searching for no he
didn't
but at two or three times he did tell me
he said Mr dunberger look at me
and he said do not be frightened look at
me
I was very nervous I was very upset
after this happened
you believe in flying sauces I have
never have believed in crying sausage
before I
honestly never did believe in it
do you believe in them now I believe in
what I seen last night I believe it was
I don't believe it was a saucer but I
believe it was an alien
some kind of an aircraft the spacecraft
or something
while driving home that evening Cole
reached out to Woody telepathically he
told Woody his name was indrid and he
went on to mention a few details about
his planet lanulus blanulus was a lot
like Earth similar water air similar
plants and animals Henry cold was part
of a crew of Searchers sent to learn
more about the people of Earth their
brief conversation ended and Woody
finally got home would he was surprised
to see a crowd of people had gathered on
his porch all very excited to ask him
questions about his encounter and
Woody's phone was ringing off the hook
everyone wanted to speak to him
researchers journalists and other people
who had similar experiences the story
became an instant sensation and was
picked up by media all over the country
every day dozens of people would appear
on Woody's property at all hours of the
day and night many would ring the
doorbell and ask Woody to tell the story
again some people just lurked through
his backyard watching the skies and this
went on for months all the attention put
a strain on the derenberger family what
his children were harassed at school
people in town called him a liar or
crazy or both finally Woody's wife took
the children and moved to Cleveland the
derenbergers would divorce soon after
that then one evening Woody came home
from work late the usual crowd had gone
Woody parked by the side of his house
and as soon as he opened the door of his
truck he heard a voice say don't be
frightened Woody it's injured and this
is my friend Carl Andrew Cole was back
and he brought company
when Woody derenberger arrived home from
work late that evening he found inward
Cole waiting for him and injured that
had brought his friend Carl despite the
late hour in cold weather Woody
derenberger sat on the porch with his
visitors for two hours they discussed
life on their home planet lanulus which
is in a distant Galaxy called Ganymede
gladulus as described by injured and
Carl is a world of profound peace unity
and compassion the concept of conflict
and hatred is unknown to them and from
childhood landulations as they're called
are taught to think of all beings as
family yet he's alien planets are always
these peaceful hippie colonies where
everybody gets along yeah that does
happen a lot America's aliens don't use
Twitter onlandulos they believe in a
single Universal God the creator of all
worlds and life discrimination has no
place in the universe where all are
equal children of this one God each
landulation shares the collective
purpose to serve the community and help
each other the inhabitants of lanulos
are technologically enlightened their
understanding of gravity and space
manipulation has been perfected through
centuries of dedicated research and
mental telepathy is a skill all
annulations learn early they believe
that if people of Earth could learn
telepathy there would be worldwide peace
telepathy discourages dishonesty and
allows everyone to understand how a
person really feels that's a terrible
idea oh yeah you don't want people to
know your thoughts are you kidding they
throw me in jail your thoughts are that
bad oh you couldn't handle these
stewards cupcake not for a second I'd
haunt your dreams
the ability to communicate
telepathically according to Legend came
into being when a group of Earth
explorers crash landed inlandulos many
many years ago their loneliness and
longing for companionship sparked the
latent telepathic abilities that all
humans have
this meeting was the first of many what
he would have with injured cold and
others from lanulos and these meetings
are detailed in the book visitors from
lanulos that Woody derenberger released
in 1971. one evening after a long
conversation Woody was invited to see
the inside of the ship it contained
technology what he didn't understand
like doors that can open and close on
their own there were panels on the walls
with cryptic writing made of blue light
and in the book it sounds like he's
describing flat panel displays though he
couldn't understand what the symbols
were Woody was fascinated with the
machine how it worked how it flew so
Andrew asked him if he wanted to go for
a ride and there was no way Woody would
refuse Edward cold said name a place and
we'll go there and Woody doesn't know
why but the first thing he thought of
was the Amazon jungle
the door closed with a hiss and then
there was a gentle vibration and in a
few seconds windows on the side of the
craft slowly opened the Woody didn't
feel them take off or fly they were now
over the jungle he looked down and saw
Tree Tops in villages and people walking
around Woody was ecstatic so Andrew
called asked him do you want to see our
planet would he smiled and nodded the
windows closed the ship vibrated and
within moments they were on their way to
another world
foreign
cold introduced Woody derenberger to the
rest of the people on board Woody had
already met Carl Ardo who he learned was
second in command he met crew members
Tani and Daryl Ingrid's wife Kimmy was
also on board and rookie mistake never
take the wife in a business trip
when the ship was within 600 miles of
the Moon it docked with a larger vessel
would he call this the mothership but
indrid called it the flagship the
flagship was bigger than anything Woody
could imagine flying it was eight or
nine stories high and at least 300 feet
long the flagship got within 50 feet of
the surface of the Moon where other
ships were parked the windows closed and
in a few seconds opened again now they
were above Saturn Woody didn't see signs
of life but he was told there was
agriculture on the planet the windows
again closed and they were off to
annulus because of their ability to bend
space and time Ingrid Cole's people
could travel almost anywhere very
quickly the trip to landulos took about
30 minutes when they arrived Woody
injured and the crew returned to their
craft and disconnected from the flagship
as the smaller ship zipped over the
planet Woody could see many cities that
injured called Gatherings there were
huge fields and forests he saw rivers
and streams and there were hundreds of
people walking around the Gatherings
there vehicles on roads and highways but
what he saw they didn't have wheels they
hovered about a foot off the ground soon
the craft landed and Woody was taken to
inward Cold's home Woody was awestruck
by the house that was made of brick and
glass there were modern devices in the
house like an automated kitchen and
laundry and everything ran on nuclear
power next Indra took Woody to a nearby
city called number 27 Gathering there
were hundreds of people moving from
building to building but they used
moving sidewalks there were shops lining
the streets not unlike stores on Earth
including what Woody described as large
department stores everything was very
Earth-like except for one very big
difference everyone was naked well
annual oceans believed in being seen
exactly as God intended
planet
chicken cow chicken down chicken chicken
so they never wore clothes except when
dancing or during cold weather two very
logical times to put on clothes it is
shrinkage I got it
so to better blend in with the people
Woody this robe get a boy Let It All
Hang Out Woody only felt slightly
self-conscious he was a little
overweight and everyone he saw was in
very good shape Andrew told him that
they are physically human but because of
their healthy and peaceful lifestyle
they typically live 125 to 175 years
from childhood they learned to control
the volume of food they eat and eat very
healthy all the food is grown
organically with no chemicals of any
kind they don't eat chocolate pork or
bleached flour they do eat lean beef but
prefer Seafood but their diet is mostly
fruits and vegetables now coffee is very
popular on the planet but only decaf you
know I like the nudity but no chocolate
no caffeine that's a problem for me yeah
you don't want to give those up I guess
they don't drink vodka I don't know
Woody didn't mention it he wasn't a
drinker 175 years is a long time to do
soba the society is very focused upon
happiness and understanding children
remain in school until they're 28 years
old yeah same as here pretty much after
school they're allowed to choose
whatever job they want if they want to
change jobs they can do that at any time
Woody said that the thing that impressed
him the most was their monetary system
people were paid not according to their
skill or talent but according to the
size of their family and general needs
them each according to his ability to
each according to his needs that's
exactly right that's Marxism yeah well I
guess it works on their Planet it sure
doesn't work on this one blanulos was a
paradise milanulos was only one
inhabited planet out of many after Woody
returned home he would come into contact
with beings from a different planet and
these beings weren't so friendly
one evening Woody and his friend Jim had
gone to a location known for UFO
sightings they had seen a craft there
the night before and wanted to see if it
would come back and after a short time a
pink UFO landed on a nearby field and
two beings that looked human stepped out
Woody and Jim began walking toward the
beings but a short distance away Woody
saw the Silhouettes Of Three figures it
was injured cold Carl Ardo and another
member of the crew named demo Hassan
telepathically Ingrid told Woody that
these beings were not from lanulos
injured asked Woody to cause a
distraction so innard and his crew could
get behind them Woody began a fake
argument with Jim to draw attention
inwards crew flanked the other crew and
began to confront them and what he
thought the altercation was going to
become violent but the beings got back
in their ship and were escorted away
Andrew told Woody that these beings were
called humanoids and were from a planet
in another galaxy and from a distance
they look human but up close there are
some differences the skin around their
eyes is very red and wrinkled and they
don't have hair but something like small
pin feathers like a bird has and they
aren't necessarily dangerous but they
tend to steal anything they can get
their hands on including humans Henry
cold said that the aliens who abducted
Betty and Barney Hill were this species
a few months after this encounter there
was a standoff between the humanoids and
inwards people involving 11 ships again
the situation ended peacefully but the
humanoids were escorted to the edge of
the Galaxy and told never return at some
point during his time with inward cold
Woody derenberger asked the obvious
question why him what did Ingrid want
with him indrid simply wanted Woody to
talk to people and share his experience
entered one of the people of Earth to
know how his people lived how they lived
without hatred and greed injured wanted
Woody to convince people to pressure
Washington to tell people the truth
about UFOs so Woody durenberger did this
to the best of his ability that's the
main reason he wrote his book visitors
from lanulos Woody did speak to the
media whenever he could he gave lectures
he tried to keep his word to inward cold
Woody derenberger died in the year 2000
23 years after Ingrid Colt stopped him
on the highway that cold November night
but his daughter Tanya picked up the
work where her father left off she met
idra called on many occasions and she
also wrote a book called beyond lanulos
that gives even more details about
Ingrid cold his family his crew and the
people of his planet and sadly Tanya
derenberger passed away just a few weeks
before this episode at the young age of
60 but Ingrid is still here presumably
looking for someone else to carry his
message and this might be the best time
in history to deliver that message
disclosure is slowly happening and
people are more receptive to the idea of
UFOs and aliens than ever before so if
one day you find yourself face to face
with a quiet smiling man a man that
somehow lets you hear his thoughts don't
be afraid you know exactly who he is
he's called cold
the story of injured cold is one of the
most enduring stories in all of UFO
history it's an elaborate detailed and
complicated story
but is it true well you can't really
debunk the story because Woody
derenberger was the only witness and
because of that we can't prove the story
either but we can look at things at what
he said and wrote and the things his
daughter said and wrote and see how much
of this adds up I'll say right up front
that most UFO researchers don't believe
the story they believe something
happened to Woody on the highway that
first night but the rest no even John
Keel who wrote about the Mothman the
grinning man and inward cold didn't
believe the story but Keel did write the
forward to Woody's book in the fort he
said whether you believe Woody or not it
doesn't matter he felt what he believed
he was telling the truth and deserved to
be heard the first clue that the story
might not be true is how beings with
advanced technology and advanced culture
are colored by the technology and
culture of the time when the story is
told like when you watch old Star Trek
episodes from the 60s the bridge of the
Enterprise looks modern and high-tech
but all the controls have big clunky
dials and switches you see the same
thing and Woody's story yes the door of
the spacecraft could open and close on
its own modern doors can do that but the
doors on inward cold ship had big hinges
like you'd find on a car and the door
made a loud thunk when it was shut and
the ship itself for some reason fire
shut out of the sides though Woody never
explains why and the culture of the
1960s tinged with Woody's own beliefs
makes its way into the story for
instance everyone believes in God the
main purpose of all of Ingrid's people
was to serve each other and serve God
the one God Woody's God specifically
Jesus Christ now maybe Jesus is the son
of God for this planet and every planet
I don't know but you think a planet in a
distant Galaxy would have a slightly
different calendar than we have but in
lanulos Christmas is also celebrated on
December 25th so I guess they switched
to the Gregorian calendar when we did it
doesn't track and by the way Woody was
very religious he later became a
Christian minister so he shouldn't be
surprised at how important God is in his
story Woody's story also reflects the
politics of the time when Indra gold
appeared America was tearing itself
apart dealing with the Vietnam War the
Civil Rights Movement was also causing a
lot of conflict Ingrid's culture implied
that there is a solution to these
problems there is a path forward without
war and without racial bigotry it's a
good message but it's a very 1960s
message on landulos women and men are
treated equally that's nice but for some
reason women aren't allowed to fly
spaceships oh why because they can't
back into a parking space that's rude
women can back into parking spaces name
one
women seem to have the same roles as
women did here in the 1960s they mostly
stayed home and raised children Woody
loses me with another piece of
technology Henry cult's people had
cameras but much more advanced than ours
they didn't use film okay modern cameras
don't use film well that's true but
Andrew called's camera was so Advanced
that when it took a picture it was
instantly printed on paper L right the
Polaroid camera was invented in 1948 but
it wasn't until the late 1960s that
instant cameras really took off now you
think that on a planet in another galaxy
the plants and animals would be
different but they weren't on the
annulos they raised cows and pigs and
chickens they ate the same vegetables we
did they didn't drink raktagino or some
exotic alien beverage they drank coffee
what will it be boys and don't ask for
Raptor Gino if I have to say we don't
carry them
then there's the issue of galaxies Woody
thereenberger didn't really know what a
Galaxy was initially the planet lanulos
was in the Ganymede constellation a
constellation we presume that's in our
galaxy but there's no constellation by
that name or Galaxy Ganymede is one of
Jupiter's moons and this detail changed
a little bit more over time and Woody
didn't know much about are planets
either he said Saturn was covered with
vegetation and that the air was
breathable on Mars and Venus and none of
those things are true Woody was right
that Venus is warmer than Earth but he
said it was usually about 100 degrees
Fahrenheit Venus is actually almost 900
degrees Fahrenheit Woody's book contains
an appendix with some really interesting
stuff he included a few articles about
himself he included his UFO reports to
the police and other groups he even
included results from a brain scan and a
report from his psychiatrist I assumed
to prove that he wasn't crazy the
psychiatrist found no sign of mental
illness but a month after meeting Woody
the string claimed that he also was in
contact with aliens so maybe a little
biased also in the appendix was the
alphabet that was used on lanulos the
alphabet was actually used everywhere
it's the intergalactic alphabet and it
looks pretty cool but the symbols match
the standard Latin alphabet character
for character it's English just with fun
characters instead of letters languages
and alphabet that's vary greatly on our
own Planet if there's an Intergalactic
alphabet this isn't it Woody said he had
many friends who also saw injured cold
and spoke with him but I can't find any
of those people the author John Keel did
say that he saw UFOs near Woody's house
but all the information about the
grinning man and the UFO sightings in
New Jersey the only source for those is
John Keel Keel said there were sightings
all over the area that week but there's
no evidence of that not in the
newspapers not even with groups like
nycap who document every sighting they
hear about Keel is also the only person
to connect the grinning man with injured
cold the young man who saw the grinning
man said he was huge seven feet tall or
taller and that he had no nose and no
ears Woody said Henry Cole was baby 5 10
5 11 185 pounds and looked perfectly
normal now Keel was known to exaggerate
for the sake of telling a good story and
he admitted this and even Woody's
daughter in a recent printing of the
book said her father embellished his
stories to help Book Sales now Woody
never said he embellished but he did say
his publisher did so the only other
witness we have is Woody's daughter
Tanya and she remembers spending a lot
of time with Ingrid and his crew but
when injury Cole was visiting she was
three years old the reliability of
children's memories has been studied to
help courts determine whether or not to
include testimony from Child Witnesses
Studies have identified that children
struggle with Source monitoring which is
a cognitive process that has to do with
attributing the source of information
young children really can't tell the
difference between events they
experienced events they dreamed and
events they just heard about by the time
Tanya was four her mother had taken her
and her brother to live in Cleveland
it's doubtful that she remembers any of
this
side note Woody's wife actually ran off
with one of the UFO investigators
working Woody's case she ended up
marrying the guy out she really worked
the hell out of that case
[Music]
the Tanya's story about injured cold has
also fluctuated over the years at one
point she said Andrew cold was known as
Valiant Thor and Valiant Thor is a
pretty famous alien story but I think we
did a pretty good job of debunking that
one a few years ago Tanya said that
injured Cole died now I suspect she said
this because she was getting a lot of
attention from a new generation of UFO
researchers like the folks from the
Hillier TV show I just received two
visitors carrying some devastating news
injured Cold age 92 demo Hassan and Carl
Ardo died today they wanted to get a
message to indricold's people and Tanya
said they could but it had to go through
her if we wanted to send a message to
you know mandrid he may have passed away
he may be in hiding but to him or even
the you know his sons that have taken
over
how do we do that what would be the best
way through me
but earlier this year Tanya said injured
cold didn't die but he was in a bad
accident still the only way to talk to
him was through her now I don't know
what he saw but at first he loved the
attention he did TV and radio interviews
whenever he could even from his very
first interview the facts weren't
perfect the UFO was hovering then it
wasn't than it was and if injured cold
could communicate telepathically why did
he ask Woody to roll down the window oh
yeah now Woody said that was so they
could see each other better fine but
doing all this media started to get
Woody in trouble he did one TV interview
that allowed regular people to call in
no it's a mistake I agree a caller named
Tom said that he too knew Andrew cold
and he had went to lanyulus Woody asked
Tom to describe what he saw to see if he
was telling the truth Tom gave Woody a
bunch of details about the planet Woody
confirmed on TV that Tom was telling the
truth when he even talks about this in
his book what what he doesn't mention is
that Tom was actually a college kid
pranking him Tom was actually Thomas F
monolioni who went on to become a
well-known science fiction writer and
later on maniliani actually admitted to
this he even said he regretted it
because of all the negative attention it
brought him the attention eventually got
to Woody too he released his book just
four years after his encounter with
injured cold but by the time the book
came out Woody's Fame had fizzled he
lost his job and his family people in
his town thought he was crazy Sue
eventually had to move to a different
state The Defenders of Woody will say he
had no reason to lie and that he never
made any money from his story well the
reason to lie could have simply been
enjoyed the attention until he didn't
and he didn't make money from his story
because well with all due respect to
Woody derenberger the book isn't very
good but injured Cole still has many
many Believers and they're out there
today telling the story and trying to
make contact I provided counter
arguments here but Believers have their
own responses to every one of mine and I
think that's okay whether you believe in
the story of injured coal or not it's
not that important to me what's
important is Ingrid Cold's message he
wanted the leaders of the world to be
honest about extraterrestrial contact he
felt that the people of Earth were
intelligent enough to understand and
ready to believe and according to
Injured cold once all of us accept that
we're not alone and that it's okay we
can move into a new period of our
history where Wars for land and oil
would be unnecessary were borders
between nations would just be academic
and were all the races of the world
would see themselves as One race the
human race now I can't get myself to
believe in the story of Edward cold but
his message that's something I can
believe in so I have to agree with John
Keel whether the story is true or not
it's a story worth telling
Gangsta heal for sponsoring today's
video click the link in the description
or go to my.huel.com to why files July
and with your first order you receive a
heel t-shirt and a guide to get you
started thank you so much for hanging
out with me today my name is AJ that's
Heckle fish and what's shaking baby
bacon this has been the Y files if you
had fun or learned anything do us a
favor like comment subscribe share I
know it's annoying to hear me say that
but I promise it really helps the
channel now like most topics we cover on
this channel today's is recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and if you'd like to
join a great Community Check out the
y-files Discord there's thousands of
people on there who think just like you
do and they're weird just like we are so
check it out it's completely free to
join now special thanks to our patrons
who make this whole Channel possible
you're amazing you're generous I
couldn't do this without you and if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month you
can support the channel keep it going
and you get all kinds of perks and if
you prefer to get something for your
money check out the white file store
plushie fish toys yeah the talking hack
of fish Plushies are a lot of fun and
you can order one now
but the first batch is selling out fast
so if you want to get one early uh get
on that that's gonna do it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
[Applause]
friends
again
but I was wrong yeah I was wrong
[Music]
when I got close
and on the street the crowd was jumping
singing songs and dancing through the
night
I didn't think that I would ever see
your face again
but I was wrong I can't believe
[Music]
while we're Dancing In The Stream
thank you
[Music]
all right